[Music]
several years ago my older brother our
older brother damien and i were
walking to our car parked in new haven
connecticut and we saw a woman next to
her car it seemed kind of distraught it
and it was raining out and
we asked her what was wrong she said oh
my i have a flat tire and
and we said you know what why don't we
just fix the tire
we're two men not that only men can fix
tires but you know and we had an
umbrella we gave her an umbrella so
she's standing there while we're trying
to figure out how to do this and i
realized that halfway through we both
realized that we didn't really know how
to change a tire i had
done it before
and i certainly seen our father do it
but it was just really difficult it was
taking us a long time and at a certain
point she started getting frustrated by
the time we finished she didn't thank us
in a genuine way she thanked us like
this
thanks a lot
and we both walked away feeling both
emasculated and maybe a little less
willing to help a stranger out which
sucks it's too bad i wasn't with you oh
yeah you would have been able to help in
a jiffy i don't think so you because we
grew up in the same house i'm just
kidding anyway here's the show life
could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream
[Music]
with me is always is my equally inept at
changing attire brother christian so
unnecessary well i just said that i
couldn't do it i was kidding yeah i know
but just in case it wasn't clear you i
don't you want to know how to change a
tire like that i know how to change look
for the record i can change one
i in theory i know how to do it i know
the steps required i just remember but
i've never done it you know so i don't
think i could do it the scary part is
when you put the um the cranker the gate
the thing that props up the car you know
the name wow do you know the name yeah
cranker
no it's uh [ __ ] as soon as i hit a jack
a jack thank you a jack
um it was a jon or a jack i don't know
james the scary part is because i've
done it before where i've put it on the
wrong part if you don't put it on the
like solid foundation
this much i know if you put it on the
bumper on the other bumper the
fender okay yeah the the like
the fray are exposing ourselves here
well here's yeah the frame gotta be in
front of the tire right otherwise it'll
rip the frame off the side it's gotta be
in front of the back tire but see i only
i know that
yeah that happened to me once on my
volkswagen golf remember that car that i
it had a blue door one of the doors was
blue the rest was maroon and i painted
like racing stripes on it it's a stick
shift 84 golf i love that car i don't
want to blame our father completely on
this no he but but but the fact is
here's the fact
he never really taught us that much
about automotive maintenance we i know
how to do basically i know how to check
the oil in a car yeah how to change the
oil in a car yep i can do that
but beyond that i can't really we can't
really do anything we can and i wish but
you know part of it is we had a really
reliable good mechanic growing up so i
think yeah shout out to john bogardi
yeah so we never really had to learn it
ourselves but i wish i didn't i do you
don't both have to wish you knew more
about auto mechanics um i do too because
it's every time i see it like in a movie
there's a scene in this movie
there's a scene in stand by me where
they're like working on a carburetor oh
remember that was a question on trivia
night we've been doing trivia night with
our friend dan schechter and um
i thought for sure a carburetor looked
like
this thing that i was wrong and we had
there it was a multiple choice and right
that was embarrassing we got that wrong
we uh we're not men in that way no but
why and why are we talking about this
wanting to be better at mechanics auto
mechanics because
our guest is the exact opposite of us
when it comes to this
yeah our guest thrives on working on um
cars and manly stuff uh
not that again i mean this is gonna make
us sound
soft no no but but but referring to
people who know about cars as being
manly no i know i almost said i i this
we're reinforcing these gender stereo
yeah we shouldn't i know but
let's say to be safe in the very
traditional
definition of what yeah manliness is one
of the things that a man traditionally
can do right is fix cars right okay and
our guest today is a very traditional
that's a good man in that way well said
well said safely said and
scary it is i know you don't want to
offend but um
our guest today you're being thoughtful
as is our guest today he's a thoughtful
traditionally
uh
adept man he's fascinating in that he is
both traditionally manly but also
very sensitive and vulnerable and
compassionate which aren't traditional
values necessarily for no man he has
both old-fashioned masculine qualities
and very new fashion one you know very
modern masculine qualities sensitive
vulnerable he's uh a good listener well
i'm dying to know tell me oh okay
here we go our guest today is kim
jong-un
sorry um our guest today is dax
shepard
uh you might know him yes you're from
where are you everyone knows him from
well now everyone knows him from are you
feeling self-conscious about being bad
at this because dax is so good at
podcasting dax isn't doesn't do a big
opening though on his show no no he's a
very good into it
uh point taken um yeah so jax is a very
popular
podcast called armchair expert and dax's
armchair expert which he uh does with
monica padman they that really launched
us we owe him a lot and we'll get into
that later i'm sure but you did to be
clear because this might be a little
confusing you're right why is dax on
because people might think oh he already
was on yeah exactly right you did um you
were a guest on his podcast a year ago
yeah that's right and that our one year
anniversary is exciting yeah this is our
one year anniversary show so that
episode one year ago
where you were the guest on his show was
on our feed for life is short as the
first episode for a long time it's not
anymore but um
that wasn't you interviewing him that
was him interviewing you yeah so um and
i remember a lot of people make it clear
this is the first time you are that he's
on this show exactly we just used yeah
and at the time a lot of people were
like uh
what's going on this is just dax a show
like you're just
it must have been a little confusing for
people maybe not maybe not the best move
on our part keeping it on the feed so
long because i think it was confusing
yeah especially because it was the first
one exactly so it was like oh justin i
want to check out his podcast why did we
do that and you click on the first one
well and it's you being interviewed well
part of it part of it was we were going
to do it back to back and i ended up
talking with dax so long a year ago when
i went to his he has a little studio in
a house that they're building and um
we talked forever and uh there just
wasn't time to do another one so he said
i'll tell you why i'm not i don't know
that's pretty good i'll tell you what
we'll just split the audio so um so this
is it so i so for those who don't listen
to his podcast the few who don't i
wonder if there are any who listen to
this and not that it's a very popular
podcast um but you also know him from
punk'd you know from
uh without a paddle uh idiocracy yeah we
talk about a lot we should maybe give a
little context because if you haven't
and the show blessed this mess that's on
the navy yes that's right with lake bell
if you haven't seen idiocracy first of
all you should it's a really great
comedy one of my favorites of that
decade and it's a mike judge movie and
dax is along with maya rudolph and luke
wilson one of the leads in the movie 500
years into the future it imagines a
society that has just kind of devolved
intellectually and dex plays a character
named fredo we get into that it's where
it's really how i got to know dax um
though i think i had met him prior to
that i don't know my memory's terrible
his memory is great uh it's another one
of the things i i really admire about
him uh which we'll also get into so
maybe we should just get into it i would
love to take a page out of dax's
playbook oh boy yeah um too late for
that i guess but here it is uh my first
technically first interview first time
dax is on our show the hilarious honest
sweet
man's man in a traditional sense dax
shepard
life could be a dream
[Music]
you know magruber's one of the greatest
uh oh i think it's the top five comedies
the last 20 years i think so too i know
a lot about you because i listen to the
show you love wedding crashers but
didn't we both have
[ __ ] we almost got roles in that movie i
did get the call saying they want you to
play
the role that bradley cooper ended up
yeah but i instead i uh um idiocracy was
happening at the exact same time oh
that's right so
the role of fredo versus the role that
cooper played seemed like i i don't know
about you but i had this like i was
aiming to be
now in retrospect somebody i could have
never been but will ferrell let's say
i was in the ground lanes and that's
right characters and i was like oh if i
go do this [ __ ] character freedom man
the [ __ ] seas are gonna part i'll be
able to play anything well but if i just
go play a dick
yeah oh that's interesting dax i
remember that time and i remember that
script that idiocracy script and so i
don't think that might sound crazy to
some people but
even in retrospect it makes perfect
sense well that's another element that
that's relevant is that the the script
for idiocracy was a 10. yeah and then
the script for wedding crashers was like
a seven and those guys made it a 10.
exactly those guys and david i remember
the exact line that made me want to see
that movie is owen goes
you know they say we only use ten
percent of our brains but i think we
only use ten percent of our hearts like
that's that's so old yeah yeah no one
wrote that line yeah
and i was like who says that we only use
timbers in our hearts who's that great
actor the guy who played the priest
he's so sweet um he's in magnolia passed
away a couple years ago um
vince has that whole scene with him
right before when he confides in him and
at the end he does this thing
he does this thing with this sweet actor
where he he goes now coming for the real
thing and he he kisses him on the lips
you remember that
sure sure absolutely i remember him
doing [ __ ] like that and it was so funny
to watch him do that because it's um you
know it's such a like power move
to take oh they're gonna be a more
powerful move than the the bigger guy
just come in and kiss i'm gonna take
some of your lips yes and i won't even
hear of anything else i want to say that
was the first time because then it
became kind of popular that the male
comedians were kissing guys in scenes
like i've seen jonah do it i've seen
will do it like yeah but i do think that
was the first i think he uh i just saw
something where seth rogen is like fully
kissing nick kroll nick kroll and seth
like like made out like with tongue i
think oh great yeah yeah they gotta yeah
you gotta you gotta top it but that but
that like that like where comedy is
going in eight years just me and you
butt [ __ ]
passionately
and we're like what a joke but we like
[ __ ] for 25 minutes that's the joke
what a laugh to keep raising the bar for
humor you got to like just get more and
more sexually graphic
[Laughter]
uh you know what's funny is during
durian chips i made that joke the guy
who created chips when we shot chips was
was older you know what i'm saying
and so he had created this very gtv show
and so he he was there the day we were
filming john and ponch talking about
eating [ __ ] i said to him i went up
to him and i said is it a little weird
to see these characters you created
now talking about eating ass
and he said yeah it's a little weird but
it's funny and i said well if it makes
you feel any better if this movie's a
success in 25 years i'll be a producer
on the new version and john and punch
will just be [ __ ]
and you'll be like uh
this might be a little bit
a little much uh
but i
to me idiocracy was was that that it
felt uh that like rebellious and
it it felt extreme it felt like kind of
a punk rock i i still can't believe they
made that movie and i've said this to
you before but i can't believe i don't
know if they'll ever be
and i mean this in the best way possible
a leading a lead character
that is that extreme that behaves like
that all real and grounded but like
that is so dumb and and it just so
excuse me are you referring to me yeah
frito uh
your character is for those for people
who haven't seen it
and now it's weirdly like relevant in a
disturbing way uh
but but you're so it's such a bold
choice to do where and we've talked
about it
it's almost too much really but it's but
it's not it's like appropriate it fits
the comedy it fits what mike was trying
to say with the movie you kind of need
him to be that slow did you come up with
it with mike or did you just pitch
something to him well i had done that
character on well first and foremost
that character starts as a dude in my
high school that's right that's right
whose uncle owned a tow truck company
and he's always talking about riding
with his uncle and hooking
like yeah i guess when you pick a car up
it's called hooking
anyways there was there was a dude who
talked roughly like that i'm sure over
the decades of doing him it evolved but
my best friend aaron weekly and i always
did that guy and then when i got to the
ground leans i did that person on stage
and then melissa mccarthy and i
had she had a character that was
perfectly suited for that character
romantically and we had sketches where
those two fell in love quite often
yeah and it was just something i had
done and then when i read idiocracy i
wanted to be a part of it so much but it
was written remember frieda was supposed
to be really
like morbidly obese oh and then i said
to mike
i really want to play freedom and he's
like oh you know i just kind of picture
this guy like you know like a big you
know like a big fat you know
and and so i was like okay well
can i at least
like a um
i can't do them i can't do my
impressions with my headset on here it's
really see him he's like a big fat [ __ ]
that's so good i think i just wanted you
to tell the story just to hear your
microphone but anyways i got to audition
for him and i started doing it and you
know i just saw i started
[Music]
[Applause]
and he's like looking at other people
and i was like oh my god he's [ __ ]
and then that just like i then i turn i
turbo down you just laid on the gas
positive yeah yeah i [ __ ] board to
the floor
and uh
and then he loved it and by the way i
don't think
anyone else loved it i think he and i
i don't think the producers were into it
i know the studio wasn't in there no
really but wow but he had that much he
had all he had so much power that was at
fox yes yes he had made them a billion
dollars on on king of the hill yeah and
uh yeah that was one of it was maybe the
best script i'd ever read best comedy
i'd ever read yeah and then of course
you know it it worked perfectly i think
it's one of the and i'm glad that people
are discovering it now you know do you
find that that people
have
found it for years no for years it was
like i just been in this movie that no
one ever saw you remember i think
contractually they had to release it
right in like 180 theaters or something
for per mike's contract yeah
but i never bumped into one of those
people that went to one of those yeah i
couldn't find it in new york i just
thought it it was
it like we did it in a dream or
something yeah uh but then over the
years and then i'll be honest in in that
three-year window i was like boy did i
choose wrong i i know everyone saw
wedding crashers
yeah yeah wow and then over time
certainly it's tied and and maybe even
above most of the movies i've been in
that a lot of people saw yeah you know
like i'd say more people bring that
movie up to me than other movies that
actually did well so well yeah you
started i was in it for one scene and
people bring that up uh a lot that one
um and you had another movie like that
called zethora which i remember being in
that
i remember auditioning for john for
favreau and this is before favreau made
marvel movies it was right before he
made marvel but it was still john fever
he had made some really great movies up
to that point uh yeah it's right after
al right after alf right so
again a part everybody wanted and and i
i heard you talked to adam scott about
this but i remember being
you adam scott somebody else that i'm
blanking on
and and myself and i remember well i was
interviewing um i was interviewing colin
hanks and found out
then that he had been offered it no [ __ ]
no she turned it down and i i had no i
didn't know anyone else read four i
didn't know anything i i was in
i was shooting
idiocracy and i got a call i wanna say
just a cold call from favreau i think it
was oh wow directly from favreau
saying hey i'm doing this movie and and
i think he was
i i was on his radar because i was in a
mic judge movie because he too is
obsessed with mike judge and that gave
me the stamp of approval oh yeah for him
wow he called me he's like i'm really
interested you for it and then i again
my ego and where i thought i was going
and i want to be will ferrell and i'm
doing this big character in this movie i
think is going to be huge i did not want
to be in zethera because i was like oh
there's a kid yeah
and i i want to be will ferrell
uh mind you elf is a [ __ ] kid's movie
so i don't even know why i thought that
directed by the same director yeah
yeah exactly and became a superstar one
second
but forget all that it wasn't fitting
with my narrative at the time yeah uh
but at any rate i was just like i don't
look i had been ten years of auditioning
not getting anything and then within
five seconds punk was a huge hit without
a pedal i just finished and now i'm in a
mic judge movie so
in my mind oh yeah who knows what's next
yeah well a lot of those
like humbling experiences make you i may
have made you i think an incredibly
vulnerable and introspective person i
think that's the best you can hope for
in a talk show host in any sort of host
like that so you certainly i don't think
would be as good as
as you are at what you're doing now
um
but i wonder if you do you think you had
would have even remained sober or
stayed married or i mean do you think it
would have been
like that i would have remained sober
i believe yeah uh
but would i have uh
would i have made space in my life to be
with kristen right no right because even
i i can give you an example
because i have been so humbled just
before starting parenthood
and i was in a period of my life where i
was like i've got the show not the
[ __ ] myself sorry just to clarify the
show you're talking about
i don't think anyone's confused justin i
was not in the movie i was only in the
show
no i'm saying rather than actual
parenthood
than the actual thing oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that's a good
point that's a good point i stand
corrected
[Laughter]
i want to clarify the tv series not the
movie right
i thought you meant the movie uh
no but but but having been
uh
really humbled because as you point out
like i did idiocracy let's go i had
three in a row that was [ __ ] tanked
and we're all good above the title yeah
i like to think some of them were good
but
i because i had
i had gone oh [ __ ] um this identity i
have where i am a movie star that that's
ground to a halt so who am i uh if
that's not the cornerstone of my
identity because that's gone yeah
and i started thinking
i need to i need a different identity i
need an identity that's not that's not
so firmly attached to my my job because
then i'm at the whim of every other
person and things that i don't control
so i was like i need to i want to have
kids like what are the other identity
things i want in life i want to be a
father i want to you know i wasn't
aspiring to be a husband simply because
i didn't believe in marriage but i i
wanted to like i wanted a partner and i
wanted kids a stable party but you
didn't really grow up with that too so
both parents got married several times
my mom in particular i think four or
five times uh but but so when i got
offered parenthood it was originally
shooting in philadelphia
and um i turned it down because i was a
year into dating kristin
and i said to myself if i go to
philadelphia for the next six years
uh this isn't going anywhere i turned
the show down which i would never do
that i would never pick someone over a
job all i [ __ ] wanted to do is have
that job for so long and then and then
it luckily for me then peter krause
joined the cast and he didn't want to go
to philadelphia either and
all these things colluded to make it get
shot here and then i was able to do it
but i had picked correct you know like i
had picked yeah this other thing i
wanted to pursue and i i finally put
something above that and then and then
the results were the opposite of what i
would expect yeah i actually was
rewarded more for that choice you know
do you feel that has been uh
something you've struggled with it's
something i struggle with is committing
to it and living with it i struggle with
sometimes um in relationships too yeah i
think they're generally hard to make and
to vocalize but i don't think living
with the choices is all that hard yeah
yeah it's like a fear of the thing is is
insurmountable and huge but then when
we're walking through it it's always
manageable yeah even like if you sit if
you sit there and think of your parent
dying
it's an excruciating thought but having
gone through it you just show up and you
do the thing second by second that
you're supposed to do and it's oddly
manageable but the fear of it is almost
unmanageable that's true that's
something that i i certainly can't
manage and you
before your
father did die that's probably something
that you
struggled with and then and then you do
it and now
yeah i mean i i i hope i don't know what
that's like for a while but um and then
you think everyone does it uh
spoiler alert you will know what it's
like eventually as we all will yeah yeah
and um and you'll be shocked to find out
that
uh that your fear of it's just is is is
almost
more powerful and more painful than
because this other thing happens like
when you when the fear of it is
loss right i'm gonna experience loss but
but the process of it is i'm of service
i'm giving to this parent i'm i'm there
for them they're seeing this thing they
created care for them at the end like
yeah the whole exchange is is oddly
fulfilling and it gives you a steam and
you like it's rewarding but when you
just have the fear of it it's just your
personal
selfish sense of loss that's coming you
know right you almost exclude the other
person from the equation when you're
thinking about it probably uh i do when
i when i'm future surfing i'm just
thinking of all the ways i'm going to
suffer from this thing future surfing i
like that what and but you also had a
lot of i got that from aaa like i've
been zoom hey
oh yeah
that's how they're doing it so and now
now i'm ended up going to meetings i
would have never gone to oh craziest
story oh wow
you'll like this so when we did
idiocracy right i got sober for that
movie yeah we did a table read and i got
an eight ball of coke and then i got a
bloody nose at a cast dinner i mean
you did it before the dinner you got
that coked up before dinner
oh i was [ __ ] i had been up front
since the night before and then i
excused myself to go to the bathroom and
then just had sat in a bathroom with a
humongously bloody nose uh and all this
paper towel stuffed in there and just
like how am i gonna return to this
dinner
with this huge bloody nose
oh maybe we made a mistake
but when i um oh no i think he would
have loved that but uh
but when the movie started i was like i
got a
for this movie or i i will [ __ ] it up
and then so i i got to austin for the
shoot
and i was like oh my god i got to go to
an aaa meeting i don't [ __ ] want to
go to an a meeting i don't know anyone
in texas i just looked up on the
directory right
and there was an address
and i walked from our hotel and i walk
up to this address and it's a [ __ ]
pink house and i'm like oh god i just
didn't want to do it right yeah we did
idiocracy 16 years ago right now
basically i think yeah wow two months
ago
i'm in austin shooting top gear
and my best friend from childhood joins
me to just hang because he's newly sober
oh wow and i go oh let's find a meeting
so we get an address no way and we drive
to this address and i pull up and it's
the same [ __ ] house and i start
laughing so much and i'm like god damn
i'm returning to this pink house with 15
years of sobriety like i didn't think
that would happen yeah it was like
really like wonderful isn't that isn't
that the best thing about that tax is
that you think uh 15 years after this
three the reason you're in austin 15
years ago is to do this thing that you
think is gonna skyrocket you and it's
gonna be the thing you know it's going
to make your life really it's going to
be
yeah yeah meanwhile the thing that you
actually stumble uh upon there is the
thing that really has that effect on
your life that that is truly monumental
and you revisit that 15 years later
that's that's really cool
uh and and so at any rate when we went
to that meeting we kind of made friends
with like a handful of people and then
we have obviously since left texas but
uh aaron
got their number and stuff so we've
joined that meeting a few times on zoom
that's awesome and i heard it there i
heard future surfing oh that's great
zoom how long you been doing it now dax
the show a little over two years in um
on valentine's day do you are you're a
year now a year well that's what this is
that you're our
you helped us
you helped me pop my cherry and now
you're um now we're you know
celebrating the we're partying the
one-year cherry pop again i've said this
to you but uh i i'm so grateful to you
man i i it's been such a joy to do this
and you really helped launch us and and
get us out there so
it's been oh good i really owe you a lot
um
is there like a dream guest that you
were
really hoping to get oh i have a few
yeah well obviously brad brady had my
number one crush yeah yeah but i thought
you hung out with him didn't you
recently
hang out yeah i did hang out with him um
but i wouldn't dare ask him to be on my
podcast i was just trying to be like the
best
possible i want to be i added a value to
you don't want to put boyfriend
his life not
yeah yeah
yeah
i want him to leave and go like god he
made that easy yeah i paid me the whole
time yeah you go to you you want him to
think like i wouldn't mind having a
little bit more of that i'm dancing
between like i'm totally available for
whatever you want and um and
and you might get me yeah and i don't
need anything from you
anywhere you want at any time and also i
don't even know if i like you so to keep
it challenging
do you find yourself doing that with
people i've done that in the past it's
really embarrassing when you
overcompensate for either knowing who
the person is or giving them status and
not wanting them to see it so you if
anything you're like standoffish
yeah well that by the way is my move in
fact yeah
the first time i was on stern
um
i had i was on stern like maybe
three weeks after he had been to la and
and and jimmy kimmel throws this party
for him every time he comes to l.a and i
had been to the party a couple times
and both times i ignore him i just stay
as far away from because i can just see
people trying to talk totally right
you're like i'm not gonna be one of
those and i told him on this show he
goes uh he goes so you were at my my
party and i go yeah yeah and he goes but
but i didn't talk to you and i go yeah
yeah because you were the hottest girl
there yeah yeah and uh
and i thought well i'll ignore you and
that'll make you curious like what is
everyone here wants to talk to me
except for this guy i don't even
recognize this guy's silently nagging me
too yeah
and
and i assumed eventually you'd have to
get my approval because i had no
interest in you
i said and obviously it didn't work
didn't he goes no i didn't even know you
were at the party
that's really funny that's really funny
but but it has worked it has worked in
the past yeah it would work on me i have
a great uh story of when it worked great
so through these bizarre set of
circumstances like
15 years ago
tom arnold invited me to go on a
motorcycle ride with schwarzenegger
uh-huh
and i'm like yes i'm there in one second
right so
two funny parts of this story so we ride
motorcycles he's the governor of
california at that time so we have like
uh secret service people blocking
intersections
and on the right is stan winston famous
who's now deceased yeah we made all the
creatures e.t right yeah jurassic park
incredible and james [ __ ] cameron
he's on the motorcycle ride
tom arnold and me right and i've only
been in punkton without a paddle which
one of these is not like the other yeah
so i i go to the bathroom right and we
we we ride up to the rock store this
little uh restaurant up in the mountains
and uh we're gonna have breakfast and
then i go to the bathroom at some point
and then when i come back
i sit down and and in sorts and goes um
so
i seen you with our paddle and i seen
the punk you're hilarious
and i was like
i was like oh my god oh my god this is
incredible so i wish i had we
i wish i could have seen your face we
wrap up breakfast and then we're outside
getting on the motorcycles and i say to
tom arnold who i'm very good friends
with i go uh uh what do you think about
schwarzenhammer knowing all my [ __ ] he
goes oh buddy as soon as you went to the
bathroom he's like who the [ __ ] is this
why is this guy here and i i had to tell
him what you were in
so yeah
i'm surprised he even got the names of
the [ __ ] right like because he just
learned yeah without it i've never heard
the word punk
i see without a punk in the paddling in
the pedaling show
where they they surprise celebrities by
paddling them
you're in the olympics
[Laughter]
so
when i was at that breakfast i did my
impression of them right so
about a month later i get a phone call
and i pick up and say could you please
hold for the governor and then all of a
sudden he gets on the phone and he goes
up
he goes back so you know i had a really
good time at riding motorcycles with you
and going to breakfast
i'm gonna i'm going to be doing some uh
some some fundraising events and i want
you to come out on stage and do your
impersonation of me
and i go uh
god that's um that's so flattering um
but you're a republican and i'm a
libertarian
and he goes
i swear to god he goes me too
[Laughter]
so he basically says he's he's a
libertarian too mind you i'm not a
libertarian anymore for whatever that's
worth but at the time it was
and so i and then i go oh [ __ ] it yes
i'll do it so so i go to this
rally oh you got it dude
yeah yeah i gotta do it so that you're
gonna love this so so i do this thing
and then this results in another but now
a lunch following the event so we ride
motorcycles we go we go to eat in
beverly hills and now
we're at a table of like 10 people and
i'm telling stories
i'm telling tons of stories i refuse to
look at him i will not look at him this
whole lunch i'm telling like his his
assistant i'll look dead dead in his
eyes and tell him the story directly to
his face
just never really make eye contact with
schwarzenegger and i'm just trying to
get him on the run a little bit and uh
sure enough like two days later
get a phone call he's like i want you to
come up to the house and watch a movie
i'm gonna be home for christmas oh man
and so i go to his home
with uh tom arnold and uh in this and
god the [ __ ] he he wears this
beautiful robe with his initials on it
when we sit in his movie theater and we
watch a movie and he he goes to sleep
right away and he just sleeps the whole
way through like at the end of the movie
he wakes up he's like i loved it did you
guys like it and
it's like my dad seriously adore him i
adore him so much oh wow i had all these
great experiences with him and i think
largely because i ignored him at that
lunch wow that's when it that's when it
transferred into like come to my house
so the lesson is sometimes it works four
percent of the time it works but when it
works
oh man oh man wait did you are you still
friends with him do you still see him
i haven't talked to him in years now
once you get out of politics uh
yeah do you think he
really was in at his core a libertarian
or or was he just doing does he just say
things to appease
he has a lot of magical gifts one is he
is so positive right so another thing
was he asked me to come roast him for
some other fundraiser and all he did is
basically read aloud from his book um
the education of a bodybuilder it's one
of my favorite books i've read it three
times
and there's a passage in there about he
and his friend franco lifting
weights in the woods naked and they did
it all the time and they raw meat and
drank wine and lifted weights naked
it's the most
it's the gayest passage of any book ever
written and
so i just read it as him
and then
and i also tell him
before i start reading i i i say at that
time catherine his daughter who's now
crazy enough married to chris price yeah
yeah
at the time was like 17 and i was 29 and
so i started the whole roast by saying
i'm friends with arnold because we've
been working to decriminalize uh his
daughter and i's relationship oh jesus
that's a bull
so
so after the roast i get a i get a
letter in the mail with the stamp of
california on it and i open it up and
it's this long letter it's like
thank you for roasting me
i don't want you to date catherine
because i don't want to have to schlep
her up the prison to visit you and it's
all on the like castaida california
station like officials so
yeah yeah it's all about him having to
take catherine to prison to see me and
so needless to say that thing's framing
oh i don't wear my house i could i hope
that's uh so so to roast him all he had
to do is read verbatim the passages
words
and then occasionally i would just be
like well it's not even metaphorical at
this point they are [ __ ] i know
they're [ __ ]
it was such a good pump when we would
eat raw meat and drink quiet like
gladiators in the roman days but back to
him being so positive
before i roast him he goes what are you
gonna do tonight and i go i'm gonna read
from your book dude this thing with you
and franco lifting weights yeah parodies
like rolling around
and he goes
and he looks right at me goes i know it
was such a great way to get the pump
like it was
he he he heard me complimenting him
that's his gift the teachers were
protesting him while he was the governor
i mean they were protesting him every
hour of the day and he goes i love how
passionately
i'm the opposite of that in a lot of
ways like i look me too yeah i sift
through and find the one potentially
negative thing and dwell on that oh you
could give me an actual compliment and i
would perceive it as a burn
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far
follow harsh reality the story of miriam
rivera on apple podcast amazon music or
you can listen early and add free by
joining wondering plus in apple podcasts
or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
how's marriage
uh how how's it going how is how's
quarantining is it
it's it's good now but but it was rocky
at first because
it's such an adjustment to a
uh when it happened i was i was shooting
bless this mess top gear and then doing
the podcast oh that's right you were in
so oh wow to go from seeing her in the
morning an hour and then three hours at
night to seeing her 24 hours a day with
our two kids 24 hours a day jesus yeah
required some um communication and some
new some new guidelines
of how we're gonna
well yeah she tells a story and i i
don't remember what the fight was about
she said
something on here that um
resulted in you guys adopting another
dog and i think it got all right right
yeah it got picked up and as a news
story are
well two things about that one i'd love
to hear your side but also
are you ever having to talk about your
relationship or anything
from your personal lives aside from
showing your kids and bringing your kids
into it is there ever anything that
you're like
this might get
this might get culled by some gossip
magazine we should maybe be i'm aware of
it but i'm not concerned about it so
the things that i get i have an
emotional response to
um
are a hundred percent of the time i have
some fear
underneath of that right so let me give
you an example
if you dedicated your entire show
to making fun of me and and every
episode you talked about how short i was
i'm just too short dax shepard's too
short he shouldn't be in business he's
too short
you could do a million episodes that
would never bother me because i'm not
too short i have no fear of being too
short if i if i know one thing about
myself is that i'm tall
it'd be a crazy show to do too but yeah
but you couldn't penetrate it because i
don't have a fear of being too short
right now if you did a show about that i
wasn't talented enough to be the lead of
a show on abc
that would bother me or if i'm not uh
that's interesting
i'm arrogant i'm arrogant that bother me
because i am arrogant or i'm a
know-it-all or anything that i actually
have a fear about it it would bother me
i don't care if a magazine says kristen
and i are going to get divorced or that
we have a shitty relationship or an
amazing relationship because i know
exactly what our relationship is and and
i'm super happy and proud of it so yeah
in that way it would be like them
calling me short like when they want to
try to make a meal
yeah i've seen that happen like we're
falling apart or something like yeah
okay we're not falling apart so go ahead
i don't care right in fact i i to the
point where it's it strikes me that you
guys have fun with it if anything you
you read those stories and like
sometimes you call them out and say kind
of like what you did with schwarzenegger
you literally just like read them
verbatim
and then oh yeah the one that we had
like some kind of um sex ring was
amazing like
and again ultimately kind of flattering
yeah like we're that sexy still
that our worst like a worse rumor to
start would be like that we haven't
[ __ ] in a year
but the notion that we're like swinging
is kind of exciting
yeah it's kind of flattering do you
remember this fight though the the fight
about the dog that resulted in you
getting another dog she didn't really
remember the details well i do and
what's funny is that's exactly what's
cycled back during this quarantine which
is
oh good my wife and i as all people we
approach things differently
and i have a lot of childhood triggers i
had a lot of step dads i don't
like to be told what to do i have a huge
authority thing so that first fight was
i came out and there was a goddamn list
on the counter of things she wanted me
to do right and i was like hey toots i
don't work for you
and you had been working a lot right
yeah yeah yeah and back to the
back to the fear thing
i feel very good about what kind of dad
i am you could she could go on tv and
say i'm a terrible [ __ ] dad
and even though that'd be a very
credible source because she witnesses it
all it wouldn't bother me at all because
i feel great about what kind of data
interesting yeah and uh likewise i feel
very good about what i do around the
house i fix all the [ __ ]
dude [ __ ] i'm managing the cars and then
i don't do laundry and i can live with
that i'm at peace with that
i do a lot of great stuff yeah i'm never
gonna walk through the house and be like
i gotta gather up a couple loads of
laundry it needs to get yeah i'm just
not gonna do it you know your domestic
lane you're very clear about your lane
i've accepted what she does
and it's been going
smoothly for 12 years so i don't think
we need to revamp anything right so when
i saw that list i was like hold on a
second this is a whole new set of rules
now so once we got into quarantine
i certainly have enough time to do that
laundry but i'm still not going to do
that laundry yeah oh interesting what
about like so that mind you i i wash
dishes i don't mind washing dishes at
all i probably wash dishes five times a
day so it's not like i won't it's not
like i'm not doing like you know quote
yeah women's work yeah i'm not a pig dax
is doing very clear i don't give a [ __ ]
about
laundry i don't go through much laundry
that's their problem that they're all
going through so much laundry
i wonder if you've pinpointed where that
may have come from that specific version
in childhood i wonder if there's a thing
in china
that's like
crazy now you're spinning here
those are funny the decks are different
yeah yeah it's
uh you know where it comes from i do i i
had a lot of step dads and they would
arrive and they were really nice at
first and then the second there was a
marriage
now it was time to do the way they
thought a house should be ran
interesting
i was the part of four different
global strategies on living and none of
them i agreed with
and when i turned 18 i said guess what i
will never [ __ ] ever be a part of
someone else's strategy to to live i
just ain't gonna do it i'm on the wrong
side of it like i am over i overreact to
that yeah you know i should be able to
just do laundry if my wife wants me to
clearly but she also understands where
that trigger comes from she's very
sensitive to your your story and your
damn yeah the really bigger conceptual
global 30 000 foot view issue that's
going on is really
hey there's a way you like to do things
there's a way i like to do things and
they're not always going to match up and
so
even as something as simple as she feels
very productive in the morning when she
wakes up that first 90 minutes she's
awake man she's on fire
and she's looking at me and i i said i
sit and i drink coffee and i chew
tobacco and try to get a dump going and
then i you know
and i have a
different window of productivity and i
just say like hey i'm never going to
have the same window of productivity of
you for whatever reason mine comes later
in the day and i don't want to ever be
evaluated
based on your
circadian rhythm or whatever rhythm you
do right now if i'm a lazy [ __ ]
call me out but you know it's not going
to sync you up the way you like it that
makes sense so that that definitely
makes sense so how did it come up again
did it just come up again because now
we're together all the time they're more
you have more time to do things you're
more available mostly she's seen me sit
a ton
[Laughter]
but let me just say in my mind in my
mind i was like dude i've got three
full-time jobs yeah this is awesome man
i'm finally gonna get to sit in my house
for a month oh my god and have a break i
haven't had in two years and i'm gonna
enjoy the [ __ ] out of it this is this is
like my summer vacation and and rightly
so she's like you know you could you
could do a little more you're a great
storyteller you're we've heard you're so
good at impressions but also you have
such great recall in a weird way i've
always wondered this because we've had a
lot of sober guests on the show and
i i wonder how it did that affect your
decision to want to do podcast was that
something that you cultivated
in sobriety on your sober well
being an aaa is the foundation of the
podcast which is
right i for the last 15 years will go
sit in front of strangers and be dead
honest and dead vulnerable
and i think we all have a fear of what
being dead honest and dead vulnerable
will result in and generally it's we
think it will result in embarrassment or
shame but through practicing that for 15
years
a hundred percent of the time that i'm
honest and own my fears what i see on
other people is not like judgment or
or disapproval it's it's recognition
it's always recognition even though the
details made different like that the
underlying emotions of all of our things
are so relatable and and so i do think
i i just through practice of doing that
it's made me far more confident in in um
and being honest so i don't think
there's no way i have this podcast
without being in a hey there's no way or
i would have maybe have a podcast but it
would just be all comedy or something
and you said this to me after i left uh
when we did the podcast a year ago i see
because i i started second-guessing
things i'd said and oh my god maybe i
shouldn't have talked about the x and
stuff like that you said everything is
on it has to be on the table you got to
be
completely honest and vulnerable and i
started thinking
are there things like that that you're
afraid to talk about that you feel
uh to be vulnerable about i guess that
the trickier thing for me is my children
because i i can't resist but to talk
about them
and they're at an age where they won't
know i talk about them i've noticed this
in stern like stern talks about
everything in his life but his daughters
and i have to assume that came from them
probably saying hey i don't want to be a
part of your show yeah but the the thing
i the thing i i walk
that's really tricky and and only time
will tell is
you know i could see where they would be
like hey leave me out of your stupid
show and then by by the same token i
could see them listening back and going
man he couldn't stop talking about me he
thought about me all day long he thought
about me when he was talking to will
ferrell he thought about me when he was
talking to sheryl crow
i don't know that i would like that like
if my dad if i saw that my dad just
could not
keep me out of his thoughts
i would like it what if your kids at one
point are like well why don't you bring
me i want to be a part of this are you
afraid that they're i mean they must be
charismatic as hell they must be like
funny i hear them in the background if
you're you know they're like little
their presence is felt it's funny and
your stories and stuff they're little
comedy insects they're like they're like
crawling around yeah
and with such great pedigree obviously
yeah they're they're um they're both
yeah really funny and charming uh one in
particular is is we call her shirley
farley cause she's a mix between shirley
temple and chris farley she's like oh my
god she can't
she can't do anything that's not funny i
mean you could watch her eat you could
watch her walk across the room she just
can't help it she's not even trying
and also she has this amazing the thing
i can't believe she has because almost
no little kid has this is she'll make a
dynamite joke
and then she does not go back to the
well she will not hit it again
because my other daughter if she she she
lands one she's gonna try three or four
more times too yeah she'll ring it ring
it oh yeah yeah ring it to death
yeah she just milk it dropped all kids
do but but my one daughter she's like
[ __ ] boom it and then walk out and then
and then we'll know when to bring it
back again it might be an hour later
i'll be like wow how does she have that
awareness that instinct of one
that's
yeah i i would never i would never put
them on the show yeah i wouldn't
interview them i wouldn't um
i wouldn't put them in a in something i
made i wouldn't put them on the tv show
i'm on i don't have any interest in
people knowing what they look like yeah
i think it's dangerous i think it would
be weird if someone came up to them was
like um your mom kristen's in the
hospital and they knew everything about
her
so much
it's just a danger thing for me i look
to you also for advice relationship
advice i think a lot of people do in a
very stable
good relationship what how do you then
redraft these rules like like uh
when you did get into the thing about
the dog uh or about the the laundry how
do you then come back and say okay here
let's get a new set of parameters going
or quarantine rules
well you know i think we do what a lot
of people do which is like we uh slowly
over the course of two weeks two weeks
uh come to hate one another
um i start imagining like where i'll
live uh when we get divorced
and then i start thinking about like
okay well i'll have the kids i guess
three and a half days a week that's not
enough for me but
yeah and then and then i'm like oh my
god there's gonna be like a dude
snuggling my children
uh yeah you know and i i just i go to
def con all right one and and and uh and
then
and then i talked to my friends about it
and then they're like you're a [ __ ]
idiot like that's never happened you
know and then we finally lay in bed and
we hash it out and then i say
why that you know uh triggered this fear
of me and she says that and then we just
and then we plot ahead and then it and
then what's great is
a week later i can't even remember being
mad at her i can't even remember like i
was
in my mind i was like you know what i'm
gonna buy a very small house with a lot
of property so i can park cars on it
this that's not so bad i've been wanting
to do that i mean
that's like a reasonable thought i had
two weeks ago and then and then
talking to you today that seems
preposterous
and uh
and i'm over it yeah it must be nice to
hear somebody else somebody that you you
know uh not a stranger but somebody that
you don't know that well say
go on about how great your relationship
seems you must be like oh you know what
i guess it is it's nice to hear
but we're we're we're
you know yeah there's no i think that's
another reason we were so open about it
is we would hate for someone to think
that it's like a cakewalk and that they
just need to find their kristen bell
because that's not how it works and so
right we just feel obligated to be very
honest about like no man it [ __ ]
blows for us sometimes too we have two
little kids everyone with two little
kids it's hard right you know do you get
sick basically if you just if you're if
your kids get more stressful like
statistically i remember when i was on
parenthood like if you have an autistic
kid
eighty percent of those relationships
end in divorce it's it's
normally high like the stress of
children is going to migrate up to you
guys yeah and you got to be vigilant
about it and it's a fantasy to think
that you're you're not going to uh hit
the skids occasionally you know well i
think that's why you're both of your
honesty the fact that you you are so
honest i think that's why that's like
the it's got to be the cornerstone
because i think about any of the fights
that i've been in relationships where
we've come to a head you know and
it's been so hard to move forward and
move past them if you're not able to
really communicate and how do you
communicate if
if you're not always being honest you
know if you're not capable of total
honesty well also there's some really
really simple tricks that all couple
therapists
can
uh
impart on people which is like
first and foremost learning how to say
when you do x i feel why yeah yeah as
opposed to you made me feel this right
right right right right no no nobody
made you feel that way someone did some
action and then you felt that way and
you may feel that way because of your
baggage from childhood you may feel that
way because some your boss just [ __ ] on
you and now that triggered that like i
just think learning even something as
simple as that is how how you express
your
your emotions how you advance too hugely
helpful yeah yeah are you sick of um
that must happen to you ladies are you
sick of people coming up to you and
saying oh you're so lucky to be married
to kristen bell
well let's just say that when when i was
um fantasizing about what house i'll buy
i have no no illusion america will
sideways kristen there's no
like that is the last time you'll see me
on any tv show selling any product
so when i'm evaluating that like i'm
also evaluating this is my exit from the
business that's part of the equation
oh that's the guy that uh broke
america's sweetheart's heart
yeah yes i'm i'm gone i'm gone yeah
uh national pariah dak shepard
um
so you know no there are times yeah i'm
i'm a normal [ __ ] person so there'll
be times like where she and i are in an
interview this happened once or twice
where like the woman was like don't you
aren't you just in awe
of her yeah
and i'm like no she's a human being that
shits in the same toilet i have i
shouldn't what no what do you mean aw
what do i think she's like from another
plant i'm like i love her and i respect
her
and i am grateful that
she's the best mother humanly possible
to my kids am i in awe of her no
who's in awe of another human being
right it'd be a weird beyonce
nice
[Music]
um okay really quick these are quick um
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say your go-to emoji that's
the most frequent one
uh probably the heart yeah yeah uh yeah
how about you you do a lot of hearts uh
yeah i've been doing more hearts lately
i like the the face that's
smiling kind of looking like smiling at
peace
i used it for i punctuated a lot of like
it sort of says this to me like um it's
got this tone
thank you yeah sure sure a humble a
humble thank you see you soon i
appreciate it yeah yeah um
just head bowed a little bit uh def
wrench a little deferential uh if you
could be a professional athlete what
what sport would you play i'd be a race
car driver yeah you'd be doing that a
lot you can't are we counting that yeah
yeah why not it's become a it's a okay
that's a sport right you're gonna hate
me for saying this but i
i would be on the fence with
calling it a sport only because and
you'll tell me why i'm wrong
because it strikes me i know so little
about it that it strikes me that it's
just somebody sitting in a
in a car
driving sharks
eating dry eating eating drive-through
and uh checking their taxes i mean i
know their strategy involved trying to
find trying to find stern on their xm
app
i know their strategy i know there's uh
certainly a amount of knowledge that you
need
uh in terms of
you know their skill
but yeah yeah yeah oh well here's what i
would implore you to do so i've been
telling a lot of people this i just
discovered it myself i had i had zero
interest in formula one i've never been
interested in it there's a netflix
series called formula one
and there's two seasons and it's it's
i've recommended it to several non-car
people and all of them have been like oh
my god i i'm okay because the
the human drama is so awesome okay
those guys are either in a car or they
are training they eat perfect they're
[ __ ] exercising all day long like
they're pulling g-forces that like a
fighter pilot pulls really and this
stamina required and then beyond that
but the the the racing i love is motogp
motorcycle racing
and those guys
are straddling this 220 mile an hour
motorcycle
and every turn they're off the bike with
their knee dragon and then they're on
the other side of the bike like what
they do physically is insane that's what
it's what an nba player does i mean no
one can get on one and do right the
amount of control that's different to me
the motorcycle i can i can see that that
having
yeah there's no steering wheel so it's
like they're throwing it into each turn
you know
favorite snack food of all time if you
could have one snack food on a desert
island oh boy uh well currently and this
has evolved if i just went through my
life i probably had to say ruffles um
sour cream and cheddar but currently i'm
into the all dressed ruffles do you know
about those number one in canada yeah
it's the canadians favorite flavor all
dressed they're so [ __ ] good
either that or oreos
favorite movie of all time i hate this
question because i i i feel i feel so
bad about not listening the other two so
i way prefer to give you three can i
give you three yeah
in the comedy genre
bottle rocket ah yeah uh flirting with
the flirting with disaster
and
uh raising arizona oh yeah
on the drama front i gotta go with thief
as my number one all-time movie thief uh
and then and then uh
probably michael clayton no [ __ ]
really i've never wow
you know in fairness i've never
seen michael clayton
uh
i would wow okay hey what i interrupted
you earlier you were talking about a
guest you really want to have on you had
said yet and asked brad pitt which i'm
i can't believe you were able to
withhold asking him i think nicholas
cage oh yeah oh man
oh man i mean he might be the most
interesting actor to ever live and he's
certainly the person that made me feel
like i could maybe do it i wrote a very
long beautiful letter to try to get him
i gave it to his agent i don't have no
clue if it ever got to him or if he
believed it if it did get to him but
yeah he
i i really encourage you to do nicholas
cage best talk show stories he's one of
the best talk show guests of all time oh
yeah i gotta watch some of those and by
the way even if nicholas cage just read
the letter that i wrote and and and
heard how much i love him that's
probably enough for me i did need him to
know
where i hold him in my heart right did
brad pitt no well so we we started
becoming friendly right and then
it got to a point where we were friendly
enough and i was going to do ellen the
next day and it occurred to me almost
every time i'm on ellen all i talk about
is brad pitt
so i felt compelled
this was the weirdest moment i just felt
compelled like i gotta bring this up
like i gotta tell him hey
and i i go like uh hey just so you know
um you know i go on ellen often and
almost every time all i do is talk about
you and she's made me paintings of you
and i together and uh you know it's just
a bit i mean i go i do love you but but
i love the the movie star uh
uh so i just i need you to know that
yeah and he was just like yeah okay and
i was like
that didn't really
yeah i think you had built up so much
but then he was on ellen and and she
said i don't know if you know this but
dax has this enormous crush on you
and then played all this tape of me
being insane about him no
but then when it ended it came back he
goes well i need to tell you i've got a
crush on dak shepard and i was like oh
fun it's
oh it's on
[Laughter]
wow um it's so weird have you read this
experience i had it recently uh
there's a movie that like
almost defines you you have like a
personal connection to it and a movie
like that for me is what about bob in
this movie christian and i did we
melanie linski was our lead actress and
she was incredible but
she hates
what about bob i kept saying did you
watch it again i know you'll like it
it was like selfishly i was like i like
it so much and i like you so much
therefore you're gonna like this and she
said that's what jason says to me all
the time jason wants me but i saw it i i
know what it is um have is there
something maybe with kristin where like
she just doesn't get it and it enrages
you
oh yeah yeah i i have that all the time
yeah but uh the time i had it the the
funniest i just had this experience i
showed my kids pee wee herman oh whoa
which as a kid i loved pee wee herman
like i used to dance like cam when he
danced on the bar
yeah and um me and my cousins loved it
and uh
the they were so
confused and frightened
and
they were asking the most legitimate
questions that i never asked they go
they go they go is he a kid yeah
and are the other adults kids and i was
like oh my god i can't even answer that
question
yeah i don't what are they nine but
they're adults
the whole thing completely unraveled for
me i was like yeah what is pee-wee
herman
well it's they're like childhood rivals
the kid wants this bike but the kid's
26. okay and he kind of talks or got
curved like
i was like i don't have the answers to
these questions
and i can't believe i just took the
whole thing at face value when i was a
kid like i didn't ask any of those
questions like is he mentally he does he
has some mental rights things going on
right
sexually where does he stand yeah it's
true
it's i but i guess dax like it's you had
said this but it's it bears repeating
that the context
in this case like the context is
everything like right we're kids in the
80s where we were slowly introduced to
pee wee herman we lived in a time where
like pee-wee's play house was on and he
was just like a figure in pop culture
that we
knew of we it wasn't like all of a
sudden we're going from a non-pee wee
world into all of a sudden this this guy
is like oh god it was like like
that's weird
yeah okay if you go almost done one
super power uh what what would you pick
if you could have a superpower it's
really for me right between invisibility
and flying yeah yeah is that everyone
that's usually what it comes down to but
you know some somebody said recently um
i would want to know every language kind
of like c-3po
oh that would be cool
i guess i'm going to go i'm going to go
with flying because i got to assume if
you can fly even when you're decrepit
and old and you can't walk you can maybe
still fly oh yeah that's true to get
around in your elder
years
um if you could uh be one age for the
rest of your life physically what what
would you
pick probably
let's go i'm gonna go with like 35
yeah
um if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal an orangutan
okay i just pictured you as an orangutan
would you rather be called unattractive
or unfunny unfunny
really oh that's all i talk about this
is what i've said
you could say anything about me but if
it ends with and i want to [ __ ] him i'm
delighted so someone could go like
that dax is such a [ __ ] dumb ass he
can't even read and he's so boring i
totally want to [ __ ] him i'm so good
everything's good i don't even care
about those first two things oh that's
really funny
uh which golden girl do you most
identify with dorothy blanche rose or
sophia
that's a new question
by the way
leslie jordan you know that
he goes before the question even came
out of my mouth he goes oh blanche
blanche and i knew her i knew rue that's
rude mclaren
of course you did who was the [ __ ]
no
that's blanche
that's blanche i mean physically i'm i'm
i'm uh i'm what's her name all day long
but i i'd like to say my spirit is that
of blanche yeah okay uh
beetles are rolling stones do you prefer
oh b arthur remember that do you
remember that it was on a um one of
those roasts i hate i mean i would hate
to be a part of one of those but i love
watching them uh-huh yeah but at one
point someone said um i wouldn't [ __ ]
you with b arthur's dick do you remember
that one yes yes yes i forgot who that
was
uh yeah that sounded like sarah
silverman maybe yeah um
if you could have uh who if you have
dinner with three people dead or alive
whom you've never met
pablo escobar
ah
he'd be in there
um
um um buster keaton you prefer buster
keaton to chaplain big time he was the
original jackie chan like what he did
was so [ __ ] dangerous the very famous
one with the front of the house falling
and he lands in the window yes half his
crew quit that day they were like we're
not gonna sit here and watch you die he
had like an inch on either side and no
rehearsal and he just stood there and
let a building fall on him and it worked
i'm attracted to all fearless people
even if they're terrible scumbags yeah
yeah i'm in awe if this boggles kristen
too she's always like how do you like
someone like pablo escobar and i'm like
right and i go hun
i'm fascinated by people's will like
here's a guy from a [ __ ] ghetto
on a mountainside in colombia and
through his own will he becomes the
eighth richest man in the world
the notion that someone can decide in
their mind that they're going to do
something like that and do it is just
fascinating to me and how do you want to
be remembered dex do you ever think
about that do you ever think about your
own legacy and your own sense of
what you're going to leave
besides your kids obviously and
you know uh i don't that doesn't
interest me at all i i'll have friends
who i can tell are actively
curating their legacy and i'm like i
hate to break it to you there's this
i get it i totally get it but this
desire to be on a great show quote a
great show i go i hate to tell you this
but
no one's gonna watch breaking bad in ten
years as much as we would love to think
they're gonna they're not gonna
my kids will never see breaking bad so
anything you do that's great disappears
like sand on the highway so if the thing
you want is prestige or acclaim or
accolades just know they're not
permanent so in that case
your life experience is what's permanent
wait on your deathbed
do you want to be on a show that you
spent eight years on that was [ __ ]
miserable so that people congratulated
you that's just not my bag well man i
thank you i'm sorry man no i don't i
love it this is my favorite thing i love
it um all right buddy thanks i can't
wait to do it again i'll have you back
now we'll just keep leapfrogging okay
we'll do it all right i'll talk to you
brother thanks buddy
[Laughter]
so
that happened
that happened you know you're sounding
to johnny carson oh yeah yeah oh
that happened yeah or uh or a little
infrared
oh
oh man should we try it again no that's
good okay [ __ ] um i mean you could try
it again sure well dax is i meant to ask
him about that uh his twang he is a
twang he does he sounds a little bit
like owen wilson when he did that owen
wilson impression it wasn't that far no
yeah that was funny you you
did your vince vaughn impression and
right away he punched back with his own
impression a better one i thought it was
going to go on forever just like an
impression the whole movie so funny that
would be fun actually to do a reading in
that movie with him um
yeah great great impression great at
telling stories uh part of it is because
he's so good at capturing people uh
their voices
as you could hear and dax and i maybe
that's how we met we used to do episodes
of king of the hill uh mike judge would
have us on every once in a while to do
kind of
random voices it was always so fun but
he has such his natural speaking voice i
just i love listening to it's
such a unique voice too but really it is
it's one it's one of many things that
make him i think
amazing at what he does on his podcast
and amazing at being a podcast guest
because his voice is fun to listen to
he is
a great listener
he knows exactly and part of it i'm sure
it's just he's been he's at his own show
for
a couple of years now so i'm sure he's
gotten
much better at this but he's so good at
knowing
um
when when to
tell a story
uh
when to ask a question he he he finds
such a perfect balance yeah so so the
conversation is fluid so as a result the
conversation is so much less of an
interview you interviewing him then it
is a conversation it doesn't really feel
like an interview right which is why i
think why his show is so successful
because it doesn't feel like an
interview speaking of being good at
listening i was just thinking about
while you were talking i saw your eyes
drift away as i was making that point
and i knew you weren't listening i was i
was taking it in oh really um
i was i swear but i was thinking about
his voice and
one of the things i i think the reason i
really like it and gravitate toward it
is because it sounds like a lovable
cartoon character doesn't he have
because he goes every once in a while
he'll go skyrocket out he goes way up
into a falsetto i know that's he does he
reminds me of like
what would he look like as a cartoon
character wouldn't he look like um
remember that uh [ __ ] what is it the
robin hood the animated robin i was
gonna say foghorn leghorn if you didn't
know what [ __ ] that's what i'm saying
yeah when he when he uh they had those
um oh the basset hound no the goose
characters would like the like skinny
legs oh yeah who were they again they
were they weren't guards were they
guards i thought they were i don't know
oh you mean the vultures yeah the
vultures they were guards yeah yeah
that's that's right yeah see and one of
them
spoke like
this there was a character a disney uh
voice actor who
did that gray that esses
was he friar talk he says like this
he
sounds like this
our mom was so good at reading
books when we were kids she would do all
the voices uh just made me think of that
she was she used to do that voice um
uh anyway yeah he has and monica on the
show on armchair
she has it's a good balanced voice
because she's kind of like a she could
be like a cartoon mouse they're both
cartoon voices yes yeah
and it was nice to talk to him again
because especially it meant a lot on the
one year anniversary of this it's been
we've talked about this all the time but
it's been such a great part of the last
year getting to do this i don't want to
speak for you
uh no it's been okay
um he seemed completely oblivious to uh
how much he's helped us ah he did didn't
he yeah he's like not so nice to hear
yeah yeah yeah maybe he didn't know but
uh it really did launch
it's something
more important to us than it is to him i
think he has
other fish to fry that makes sense um so
anyway we will always be grateful to him
for that and uh and and so great
catching up with him i just love i feel
like i know him so well i've always
known i've known him
he's been like a peripheral figure in my
life uh over the last 15 years maybe but
since listening to his show and i'm sure
all of you can can uh attest to this you
feel like you know him yeah
i i so well he's just so honest on a
show and so open well and because
he
exposes his personal life so readily
yeah and and even if you're not someone
who reads like gossip columns like i i'm
not one of those people but even i
managed to
catch wind of what he and kristen bell
are doing it's it's it finds its way
into uh in the zeitgeist yeah well so i
feel like i know them as a couple kind
of well do you follow her on instagram
right i don't oh
sorry for outing you that's right she
might
follow me
yeah you guys talked about idiocracy and
how it's gained in popularity over the
last few years and i've noticed that too
that people seem to bring that up with
you
yeah pretty often now and i remember
back after it was out back after you
made it for years nobody saw it like
every once once in a blue moon someone
would would say and i remember your
reaction was always oh my god you saw
that that's amazing well but now it's
really taken on like a real cult status
i think well i think it's two reasons
cable and streaming um people have just
discovered it because it's good right
funny maybe it's maybe that's the big
reason
yeah i mean it is really good maybe but
they're also frightening
parallels
that are you know reflected right in our
current i i don't think that that's why
it's become i think i agree with you i
think there are parallels but i don't
think that would be the reason that
people would be like oh there i heard
there's a movie about this uh thing
that's kind of happening now and it's
and it's scary like i'm gonna watch that
comedy i don't think that'd be a reason
to motivate people to watch it i think
people just discovered it you know
that's what happens over time it's
i love reading about movies that um did
you didn't do well you know when they
were first released and then a couple
years later like daisy confused nobody
saw that when it came out maybe also
because he's become more
popular more famous so maybe dax has
something i want to check out this movie
he starred in that i never watched terry
crews was in it maybe yeah when i was
doing dodgeball the producer of that
movie stuart kornfeld pulled me aside
and he he said what do you want to do i
said well i don't really know what's out
there what what should i do you know he
said well there's this i want you to
read the script just as an example of
the comedy that that could be made but
they're never going to make it it's
called 3001 he gave it to me and i read
it that night it was it was the best
kind and i say this to tax best comedy
i'd ever read so it's my favorite type
of humor too smart dumb humor you know
when i gave it back to him he i said
well why why do you say no one's going
to make this and
he said well it's because it just won't
get made it's too um
it's too anti-establishment it's too
anti-corporate yeah yeah and
specifically and you need a budget
to make it and you can't get a budget
without a corporation behind you and so
the only reason mike was able to make
that it was because office space had
done so well on video and king of the
hill was such a huge success yeah
for [ __ ] for fox i guess that too
probably but i think it was more off
space he had this deal there that was
like and that's why jax mentions this it
had to come out i mean if they had their
druthers the studio would have just like
never probably released it but it had to
be released and i'll never forget i was
in austin
which was also the first time i'd ever
been to austin was to shoot it then i
was in austin again uh when it came out
and
and it was playing at
the uh great theater they're called the
alamo draft house but um they didn't
have a poster for it it was or they had
like an old poster and it was called in
the paper it was listed as untitled mike
judge project still they hadn't even
bothered to put the title
in the paper and it wasn't playing
anywhere in new york city weird any who
um you guys talked about how
men are are uh like taking more risks
with each other and like uh jonah and
other actors are like starting to kiss
more amorous you're joking about yeah
yeah i'm talking about that and then you
said well eventually that the future is
going to be the two of you just having
sex with each other you used a different
term um
you use the term [ __ ] oh yeah is
that offensive now uh he used it i think
okay so you're saved all right okay good
uh and this may be a crude observation
that i'm about to make but
uh
i
unfortunately i had to picture that
scene in my head after it was said
i pictured that scene in a movie and why
unfortunately that's homophobic well you
know i'm kidding no but um but but the
scene i pictured clear as day
without question
the position was very obvious who would
be in what position
and i don't want to say
i don't want to say who would be in what
position but oh yeah but don't you think
it's obvious who would be in what
position if the two of you were in that
scene
yeah unless and not just because he's
better at changing uh flat tires but
that has something to do that has
something to do with it yeah
no yeah he's certainly the alpha he
would yeah
he would what he'd be the top dog
so to speak so yeah yeah well i don't
know what you're saying no i don't
either um that's funny
um that he makes a very interesting
point about uh he talks about
the fear fear in general but
specifically he says the fear of a
parent dying is worse than
actually going through the process of
dealing with a parent dying but you can
apply that to any anything in life any
fear uh a fear of committing to a
relationship the fear of
uh you losing a job or whatever um and
it's such
a
great thing to keep in mind in life i
think that the fear of something about
to happen is always going to be worse
than the thing itself my our dad always
used to say cowards die many times
before their death remember that it is
yeah he was always in the context of do
you know what i'm going to say
uh when would he always say to me
i don't remember it was it was uh when
we were
oh shot yes yeah i wasn't scared of the
doctor like we needed to get our
physical done i was tougher than you
were as a kid
were you yeah in fact
i think because you guys were so afraid
of the doctor i would take pride in the
fact that i was brave so i would play it
up as much as so even if i was a little
scared i would pretend like i wasn't and
really because i remember mom being like
you are so brave and i got so much
validation
from that it made me feel good the same
thing happened with uh eating a lot of
stuff you got validation from how many
things you he's such a good eater
exactly so therefore you develop exactly
i may not have loved zucchini but i
but i acted like i did and i convinced
myself that i did i think i hated
zucchini so much i still do i hate
cooked zucchini still who cares
something dax wouldn't say in his but i
can't uh or he'd make an interesting
point about it although raw zucchini
delicious isn't that weird what why why
should something like raw zucchini yeah
i made it the other night and then
spring salad
oh yeah if you guys haven't heard the
last couple episodes uh
justin is has become a housewife and oh
by the way i was doing and i i have
poison ivy all over my arms um i was
doing that's pretty manly yeah i was
clearing out some bro yeah some manly
things took a chainsaw out of those
bushes down there i cleared out some
brush
that is pretty manly yeah thank you
but now you keep in a traditional sense
but now you have to spread calamine
lotion all over your body
so the manly thing you did was now now
you have now you have pink stuff all
over your body i know which i got over
the all over the couch last night it was
a funny sometimes i catch myself in
these moments and i can't believe that's
what's become of me uh point of
clarification you said kristen bell
didn't remember
the uh the details of that story of that
it's their big fight oh that's ironic oh
yeah um but the truth is you didn't
remember the details of the story and
then as he told the story you started to
remember that's right but just for any
listeners any pro kristen bell listeners
she did remember the details oh she did
oh yeah that's funny
oh that's funny i that i put i projected
that on to her yeah
but though we are very similar too i uh
i don't know how to bring that up to him
you and kristen bell
yeah we have a lot of similarities like
we are both the accent thing how we have
to you know
start we slip into people's accents when
we hear them um
we are terrible memories
we both
i think you and dax are pretty similar
too
do you think oh that's complimentary
you're you're wow so you're complimented
by dax yeah well look this because the
yeah i mean the christian things uh oh
oh does that mean i like dax more no i
just you're just more impressed by him
well
yeah i guess so chris and belle fans are
going to come after you
people like the beast like the bay hive
there's that
that was funny you're like uh-oh the
beehives didn't come after me either
did i say
you may have said bam i don't i actually
don't know what it is it's beyonce so
wouldn't it be the bee hive oh no
queen
queen bae yeah aren't you scared of
saying anything
wrong or bad or wrong about beyonce no
like that oh because no one's gonna give
a [ __ ] if i say it but i know if you say
it the thought of the beyhive coming
after you fuzzing out brings me
so much joy
what's jc's
crew call the the z the z
i boys know but it i hope if any beehive
members are listening
please come after justin i'm sure there
are some there's so many members of the
bay hive but you you you said she's
quite queen bae she's queen bee i know
you prefer dax and kristen to jay-z and
beyonce but you're not saying
they're more impressive people you're
just saying you you align more with what
they do of course the things that
they're good at and they do i value more
exactly
that's not to say anything discouraging
about what they do now it's more it says
more about me they're like incredible at
what they do
there's a reason they're the king of
queen i have to talk of course the
merits of jay-z and beyonce no you don't
he was talking about their funny kids oh
my god they must be not only must they
be
just the best special and what pedigree
that is
but when they they said that one of them
is they call him shirley farley the
visual of shirley temple
mixed with chris farley is a really yeah
because you know no one knows their kids
look like and now i think one of them
looks like a hybrid of shirley temple
and chris farley aren't you just
picturing chris farley in a shirley
temple outfit like
uh i'm a good chip lollipop you know
what's funny i was picturing the
opposite i was picturing shirley
temple's head on chris farley's body
weird yeah oh i pictured farley dressed
up as your maybe because you're more
aware of what chris farley's face looks
like
so that's what you picture maybe i don't
know why i'm so aware of what shirley
temple's face looks like but i but it
jumps to mind isn't it strange that i we
know shirley temple's face or i do
anyway very well but not the way it is
now
i mean when she grew up i i i know i
know well because she wasn't correct me
if i'm wrong
she wasn't really famous as an adult she
was she was like an ambassador no but
she didn't she didn't stay an actor no
no right
yeah or did she
no she didn't i don't think shorty's but
uh recently i just saw jonathan lip
nicky
he became an adult he did no i know but
he have you seen him i have he's i know
his face so well from jerry maguire he
is uh muscle bound ripped yeah his taxes
ripped let's get back to dax speaking of
he is what a great body how come you
didn't talk to him about that
speaking of great bodies this thing with
brad pitt
aside from the obvious
what is it that he why is he so into him
i think it's both the it's that and it's
also i
you know that quality that brad pitt has
that's that's sort of cavalier and off
the cuff and cool i mean it's just like
well that to me that's part of the
obvious stuff right yeah he's he's
beautiful and
cool that's uh a great actor i think
it's all the things you know dax
who wouldn't like him i guess but see i
think in this is when he answers the uh
would you rather people find you an
attractive run funny question
uh that speaks to dax is how much he
values
and maybe he's insecure about his looks
well that's what he says in general that
he i thought that was very interesting
that when there's a gossip story about
him or
or them about uh with his wife
he doesn't care at all as long as it's
either um
something he's secure about wrong yeah
that he's secure about yeah like being a
good dad yeah
right
so so it doesn't so it's all it all
comes back to
his own sense of
security and what he values and so if
you are someone who values looks which
he's open about which i think is is
really impressive
it doesn't stand to reason that you
would fetishize somebody like brad pitt
who looks like the male you know
it doesn't get better than that he's
like the male beyonce
yeah
um he uh
i want to try the all dressed right that
was the chair did you hear that yeah
all dress ruffles those sound delicious
oh yeah that canadians love yeah it was
really funny when you asked him the
golden girl's question and he goes he
goes which one's the [ __ ]
the who were who uh
yeah maybe you know
is that an effect he's i don't know i
don't know i feel like he says offensive
things but he's so honest about us that
he gets away with it because he's
established himself now
as this
like
completely vulnerable open book and i
think when you have that reputation
that's true you get away with a lot more
that's true and kind of like he's
approaching as i know he really idolizes
him but he is approaching howard stern
territory in that sense yeah they're
similar yeah and i think another
similarity i think the reason
they are both so successful is that
i you just said this but he's so honest
he's just it's he's honest about his
flaws about his qualities um but his
marriage yeah he's wonderfully admirable
it's one of his many gifts i think yeah
i just really i so admire that um
let's read a letter you were saying it
earlier he's just like you know how
people talk about especially on the
shows like bachelor that we watch that
that term real he's real that's always
used as like a currency um
you asked him about his favorite emoji
and he answered and right away he said
what's yours and he didn't ask you like
i think often in conversations people
ask
questions in order to either fill space
or to appear interested or oh my god
especially with actors but he
i seems to only ask questions when he's
genuinely interested in what the answer
might be
um which is oddly rare i know i know and
and
which is what makes him really good at
what he does because he's not asking
questions that he knows he's supposed to
ask a guest he's asking questions that
he's genuinely interested in yeah and
you can hear that you can um
yeah it's really engaging it's what
makes him engaging yeah um okay
enough enough gushing about it
is that
i know it's great he's great he's great
and and he's a great guest he was a
really fun conversation oh yeah i
enjoyed it and he was right too i like
that he said that about um we wouldn't
have done it if it weren't for this so
true it's another one of the true um
reasons i love doing this it's like it
demands that you as my friend betty
gilpin always says water relationships
what are your relationships um okay
afton this oh wow what a name i wish i
could say the last name this is from
afton b
subject maggie q and baseball talk hi
justin and christian long time listener
first time writer thanks afton i've
never said that before thanks afton
i've never addressed an afton i first
stumbled upon your podcast from justin's
episode on dax's shepherd's armchair
expert i got too excited
for that i did i got excited because i
saw it coming
there you go thanks dax and i have been
hooked since
your episodes bring me a lot of joy and
introduce me to fascinating people every
week i especially appreciate your
quarantine episodes which have been
keeping me company on my walks that's so
nice to hear
i just finished listening to maggie q's
episode and her love of animals
especially dogs really resonated with me
her story of singing to her dog while he
passed tugged on my heartstrings
especially because i just had to say
goodbye to my own furry friend just this
morning i got wow that day
the timing seems so strange yeah i bet
but i definitely needed maggie q's story
to help pull me through this extremely
difficult time oh man life is so short
and we need to hold on to our loved ones
as tight as possible while we can thank
you so much for introducing me to maggie
and thank you maggie for sharing that
story i hope she's listening otherwise i
will tell her that that's nice on a
lighter note i have asked my boyfriend
who is a huge yankees fan about oh boy
about the christian versus derek jeter
discussion
my boyfriend says quote
i don't know how good christian is at
throwing a baseball so i won't rule it
out that's a really good impression of
her boyfriend i don't know what happens
wait can you repeat that line yeah he
said i won't do as an impression of
someone i've never heard uh the boy my
boyfriend says i don't know how good
christian is at throwing a baseball so i
won't rule it out
that seems better that's nice
we'll see that's what she goes on to say
before i react to that okay that seems
better than most of the responses right
i'm also a huge red sox fan so i'm team
christian
whoa whoa yeah but she said someone is
yeah but she's team christian because
she hates the yankees well and she wants
you to be better at it also the debate
wasn't about who could throw a baseball
that's true but everyone keeps getting
this wrong but uh my money is on derek
jeter throwing lefty or righty or we're
throwing with his foot
throwing with his pinky all my money's
on derek jeter yeah throwing with his
mouth
uh thank you both for all the fun
conversations proud to be a shorty proud
to have you afton uh sending all the
love from upstate new york uh love
upstate new york best wishes afton our
whole family's from upstate new york um
rochester to be exact
so we spent a lot of time going up there
as kids driving up there the taconic
thanks for writing in afton yeah yeah
and congratulations on your cool name
what a great name and thanks for being a
shorty and thank you all for listening
for a year yeah that's really cool and
another cool name rare name thanks to
our good pal dax shepard
uh and uh obviously check out his if you
don't already you probably do armchair
expert and uh bless this mess on abc
we are always gonna be so grateful to
him so thanks buddy and if you guys want
to write in with the letter uh our email
address is
life is short at wondery.com
and we will see you maybe in a couple
days for a quarantine and check we will
uh
yeah we'll uh check in in a couple days
yeah okay and i don't know and as always
um we love the would you rather
especially if you have kids you want to
ask your kids
um okay thanks guys thanks dax
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced by you christian love
and megan monaco senior producer is
michelle miesh lans audio engineer is
sergio enriquez executive producers are
marshall
louie and hernan lopez for wondering
bye thanks for listening for a year yeah
one year happy birthday justin happy
birthday christian we're blowing out our
candles
okay go again thank you
okay
yeah
no just say you know just say oh alan
picked me up traffic was a proper
nightmare proper nightmare yeah it was a
proper mayor you know like proper elm
streets you know what i mean
elm street even i know that one yeah
well what was someone you said before uh
scott uh
uh [ __ ] the scarf one i'll go for a
laugh yeah i came for a laugh i wish i
brought my game for a laugh
you know you've wrapped that around your
gregory's you know what i mean my
gregory gregory pick oh my god oh my god
amazing okay i know thank you
hey i wish i had an extra game for a
laugh here we go
do you what now
what is this
what's your
that's what i'll say now just just say
stop recording okay
you